who is the one that you try to impress
that you try to like you hope you like
your work that they don't say much to
you about your work that
is the hardest because we all have
somebody in our family
mine is my dad he's just like you know
he doesn't say much
of anything at all
um
this this sounds like a cop-out they're
all supportive of my work but i would
say the voice in my head of the person
that i always that would it would be my
mother
yeah
yeah like i think that letting her down
by either like you know when i talk
about howard stern or
doing a part that was
you know when i was a kid doing
something topless doing those those
kinds of things i was always worried
to let her down even though i know
nothing i did do would let her down but
she's my voice in my head right
you know mom
yeah
makes sense all right the best lady i
know i'm not knocking her but she
definitely is like when that stuff
happened i went
[Music]
whoa i just went against like every
single thing my mom tried to program
into me not just well we got to go our
own way fleetwood max said it you got to
go your own way and sometimes along that
way you're going to fall or sometimes
you're going to look like an idiot or
sometimes you're going to be a little
embarrassed and that's all part of it
i'm i'm mortified half my uh half of my
life
but you know the thing with my mom which
i find interesting is like i worry about
all those things but then she's my
deepest supporter if that makes sense
so
it's almost like i've imagined i put her
in this space of judgment but that she's
not actually in that space
that's my own judgment and she's
like any time i've talked to her about
any of those kinds of things like her
her support and her love and her
understanding of humanity and stuff is
just boom it's there right so as you
know probably i don't know if you
figured out when you do
if you i don't know if you do it um but
i'm currently doing therapy it's like
the narrative that you create is your
narrative right
and it may not actually be what's
happening right in mouse's head yeah
kind of put it there
huh
that makes me think a lot by the way
with all your pieces and all the things
that you're you know insecurities and
then the cool thing is is once you start
realizing that
then you can kind of go oh
i'm putting this on there because
this is a thing for me right i didn't
know you were topless in something oh
yeah it was awful really
awful yeah you hated it how many years
ago was that
i was 20. it was my last credit to get
in the union
wow
were you nervous that had to be crazy
and you know what i have to say i didn't
want to do it i mean it was it was not a
pleasant experience for me and i would
challenge anybody who's young who feels
like they don't want to do that stuff i
don't know anybody who'd have the hoots
but to do it maybe the girls of this
generation more power to them but i
remember i was kissing my on-screen
boyfriend matt he's just a lovely person
and i was crying and i was like i don't
want to do this
he's like you don't have to do this i
was like i have to do this and then i
just continued to do the scene where i
like tease them when i go out into the
water and i
write right and it looked awful it was
terrible
and you know they didn't tell me about
like supposed to be topless and then it
ended up being i oh let's take your
pants off to you and then i hadn't
prepared myself for that so then i was
wearing really inappropriate underwear
so like it ended up being like a full on
basically they took advantage of you
sounds like and then i find out later
from all my friends who are in
in um
crew and everything they're like oh yeah
we we had our stunt girl one guy was
carrying a hose the other guy was
carrying like it wasn't a close set i
didn't know about that i was so [ __ ]
scared oh my thing but i'm so driven too
so my brain was like
six credits i'm in the union then i can
be a union background performer and i
can make twenty dollars an hour
and then i can try to audition for
bigger parts and so my brain just went
[ __ ] do it eric i like to get past
all the stuff from your childhood this
is your awful
and now i realize no that's probably
part of my makeup like i really didn't
want to do that thing